so Connor you told your parents you're
going to be a millionaire by the age of
25 you were actually 26 can you believe
the Hollywood movie star lifestyle would
you not just give me that no more than a
couple of months I was 24 I'm only
Messing I was 26 that's that's some good
research lady so yeah no of course I
believed in it I had to believe in it if
I didn't believe in it it would not
happen so I certainly believed in and I
believed in it so much that I could put
that I could predict it give or take a
couple of months but I got there how to
deal with all the fame and all the money
I mean it's not like after that may what
if I won the lotto I was already like I
said I was number 24 on the Forbes list
this year before the Floyd for 24
million in revenue in 2017 I was I did
not hit the jackpot I've been I've been
in this position a long time it feels
now so and I certainly enjoyed the money
I certainly enjoyed of Fame I enjoy life
to the fullest and there's certainly
highs and lows to it but the lows aren't
really low was there like I said people
have real problems that the problems I
have are not are not actual problems so
I'm very happy I'm very proud to be in
the position I'm in and long may
continue now I continue to enjoy you
must still lie awake sometimes go I used
to be a plumber yeah I mean a lady yet
someone asked me earlier what if my son
would want to be a plumber and I was
like a little take him back wait a sec
she wanted to be a plumber and guide him
into a but I would be I'd be shocked but
yeah I was a plumber originally and a
tough tough game the air plumbing game
especially as a first year here in
Romania I carry are sent down to the
shop sent down to get the points you're
carrying them up then you have deepens
in someone's toilet pot it's a hard one
so oh my god out there quick and
thankfully I did it's very handy skills
well I didn't really learn much skills
originally I mean I was only a fourth
year so I can make a fine cup of tea do
I tell you that much
and in the film you are a real force of
nature and you know people stop you in
the street they love you almost like a
gods in Ireland isn't easy to do with
that level of adulation actually that
was early stage as well you're
witnessing that it's another level of
crazy all together now so it's something
that I've become accustomed to
I just embrace it I could let it eat I
could let it swallow me up and shy away
from it I could eat it and
rise up and stick my chest out and enjoy
it and embrace it and that's what I've
chosen to do and that's what I do what
impacted the many weather fight have on
your life that whole time there was many
ups and downs with the media was it was
intensified but it was not any bigger
than I was used to where I've been
involved in big mega fights before
obviously this was the biggest and two
of the biggest stars from two different
worlds colliding it was it was
phenomenal but my life is I certainly
have a lot more money now but again I
already had a lot of money before then
as well so my life has not changed too
much it's just about managing my
finances managing the Empire that I have
built and managing the different
entities that I am engaging and trying
to grow them into billion-dollar assets
and that's where my life is right now
and you walked away the lot of
credibility after that fight did you
feel satisfied with what you did in the
ring or can you ever feel really
satisfied if you don't I said I just
enjoyed a whole experience I certainly
certainly took the early rounds handy I
was told he was faster I told I was gone
I told I was I was told I wasn't gonna
land a punch I was told I shouldn't be
in the same ring bla bla bla bla bla
show me his highlights show me as
highlights in the fight you can the only
thing they can show me is around 9 and
10 when I'm completely fatigued and the
stoppage happens show me any order
highlight before there's known all the
highlights of of me some beautiful walk
I landed on him
I'm happy with how it went of course I
went in to win it didn't go my way he
changed up his game plan three times he
went from his Philly shell style to his
rope-a-dope style I was picking him off
on Bolton our Styles and then he changed
up a tour a tour change of game plan in
the middle of fight and went Mexican
star hands up
knuckles above the eyebrows dipped in
low and start walking forward it's a
style of fighting that caught me off
guard because he never fights like that
I did not prepare for it and I did not
anticipate it and ultimately it got him
to win so much respect to him but it is
what it is if I got an order go I would
beat him you're a role model whether you
like it or not do you ever regret some
of the things that come out of your
mouth of course I mean I must always
remember that I'm a role model and I'm
an athlete and a man and have a kid and
I'm still trying to figure that part out
I do put my foot in it I do say
offensive tastes all I can do is when I
do say things just put my hands up and
apologize to those offended and that's
and move on and hope that people accept
my forgiveness and and and not look
towards to not look to too much at my at
my mistakes and failures and look
towards more of the good things that I
do and my successes and and carry on
living life and that's it how much of it
is you when those things are said how
much of it is to sell a fight or to get
a reaction I mean I I am human I ask I
am angry at some stage I am happy at
another stage I am sad it's it's all me
it's not it's it's all me sometimes you
put your foot in it sometimes sometimes
you don't it's it's part and parcel of
being under the microscope that is
whatever it is I don't even know what it
is it's it's the microscope of the media
you recently called an opponent a [ __ ]
which is called caused huge controversy
did you mean to do that I mean
homophobic slur yeah I wouldn't actually
I wouldn't actually like after I said I
wouldn't ring of many gay men II gay
friends and many friends back like I
cannot campaign that when when game Eric
when we were campaigning for a game I
said to legalize it I was a big
campaigner for it so I am NOT against
that at all it wasn't like I was
shelling out to people of the same sex
kissing or I was having a conversation
with a friend who lost a career
potential career and then fight an
athlete you who gave so much of his
mental health his brain health his body
health
means prepare and spar so I could put my
health and my brain health and mental
health on the line for the public and
then I watch him lose that fight against
an opponent he was running away and
stalling and I used to attempt to
describe it it was the wrong time as it
itself is it is a very offensive word
and it is what it is it was I have to
just put my hand up and apologize to
anyone that was offended but I wouldn't
even bring any of my gay friends and say
hey I'm sorry did you hear I said I'm
sorry I said that because I I wouldn't
even call that's not what I didn't have
any of that in my head at all it's it's
a different it's it was a different mean
and in my anatomy at there's different
meanings to it but it's an offensive
word and I shouldn't have said it and
I've got to just hold up my hands and
say and say I'm sorry for anyone that's
offended and again carry on and hope
people can accept my forgiveness what if
Connor junior started to copy some of
your fight taught your trash talk when
yeah when he starts to talk would you
quite cool with that the fight game is a
cruel and rootless business you must get
in there someone is gonna have to duel
me grievous bodily harm
like really someone wants my hair
drilled into the floor at a hundred mile
an hour it is what it is you're gonna
say things when you come face-to-face
with a person who was trying to do that
to you he was trying to hurt you he was
trying to make me for a life and he's
trying to take food off your table
that's gonna happen so if he is to say
it it is what it is
III will just hope he I don't know I
don't know maybe you just need to take a
few words off the list that I think
maybe I could do that a little bit
better bombs again I'm still trying to
figure out the whole thing this I'm only
new to this let's be real five years ago
I was in I was in the queue for the
Social Welfare five years ago in order
me in a hundred a hundred and eighty
eight euro
I collected stood in the post office
didn't even had no job a last diploma
job I'm not them that's what I was five
years ago now I'm like the president I'm
like a politician or anything if I if I
sneeze it's in the Nils and it's all
over the place I'm still trying to
figure it out
little alert I still trying to manage
what way I go about it so please be
patient with your president what are
your top tips for trash-talking do you
plan it do you practice it or is it just
you know naturally trash talk is an
American term it's an amusing one to me
I never speak trash I just simply speak
truth but it may were to build a
particular level of it somewhere for the
20,000 people every single press
conference and there wasn't even
questions you Judas questions you asked
me a question about an opponent and I
answered it to the best of my knowledge
truthfully to what I believe he is or
what way he fights or whatever this one
I was I was forced to just roll out and
start talking that was a new experience
for me but I didn't think anything I
didn't plan that then I had a few quick
I just imagined questions being asked to
me and what way I would respond and then
just rolled with it and then of course
sometimes emotions got away with it and
I let it roll and I turned some tornado
gold some torn into not so well it's a
skill set it's it's it's a skill it
ain't easy so I roll up there with
20,000 people and then trying to Rachel
that having a guy that's gonna there's
gonna smack the head of you if he gets
the chance
it's an unusual it's an unusual game
it's a very addictive game among the
fighting the blood the trash talk in the
film the really sweet part of the film
and the really human part the film is
your relationship with Dee how much has
she been on this ride with you and how
much you attribute yeah she is the only
boss of the whole thing she is a she is
a female boss she is an intelligent
woman strong-minded she has been by my
side this whole time and I'm very very
grateful for it she she has been she has
been the rock to what all she's been
inspirational and motivational to me
when I needed it most so I'm very very
grateful I'm very grateful there we have
a song together and life is good I am I
am extremely blessed in my life when are
you going to get married cuz Ireland is
waiting for the royal wedding yeah look
I only drop mad money on a
Krishnan came to me with the christen of
the babe you want to do this and Ferris
wheel and clothes and fire breeders are
my water and then I'm hitting with a
bill for that like right well I'll do
this but chill on this wedding for a
minute so just give me a minute
I'm only I'm still I'm still you can use
for this marathon is it I'm married are
what is it your ring and a big event is
it just for the flash is just for the
flaunt or what is he
you know me and so I don't know I'm just
trying to figure it out but don't be
rushing me lady right now afterwards me
you know he comes to your house in Vegas
and he wants to meet you and he's and
he's talking to you and when he leaves
you and ear behind the dog he does not
have not now superstars want to meet you
yeah I've got yeah so people come into
my life and I mean I mean oh I'm in awe
of it
Schwarzenegger not necessary from his
movies and I know I don't know every
single quote that he's ever had in a
movie but just his whole store oh I'll
be back I know but they treated him with
bullet points there I tried the name
quotes in his thing and I had to guess
which movie and I flopped every single
one of them look I'm not a fan of irony
but ass I'm a super fan no but I've I
mean all the story camp not miss he came
over I couldn't even speak a lick of
English got a roll could speak three
words in English and those three words
I'll be back made him you know and they
became the Governor of California the
only reason you become president was
because he wasn't born in America he was
he essentially brought California to
Ojai
he's an he's an animal an absolute
legend and to see him sure about me
helps in Vegas that I had it was it was
like I said it was what off what what
they if you know I mean and that's
that's what it was and of course it
happens more and more and I've met them
all I mean here Tom Hanks
alright not Tom Hanks to me Tom I'm
sorry I've met them all I'm I mean I've
met many many great great people and
that's I know you'll want to meet you
what is the long-term plan because the
fight business is is a very tough
business so you must have a plan
I've got X in the bank I will stop and
then do I always look at the end from a
damage taking standpoint how much damage
have I taken how is my how is my brain
how is my mental health how is my
physical body
how is my train and how was my
preparation how is my hunger for it and
that's where I get where how long I'll
do it and there's still a lot left in me
as far as revenue the revenue is forever
money my money's right up here and it's
gone you know it's not like that just
gone rallying around that's forever
money the end of these I am involved in
that I am building up the August malaria
clone like the whiskey I have my own
news site I'm like I'm like a young
group with Mourdock with this with this
my crafting I'm creating I have so many
entities that have the potential to
reach billion-dollar status in in no
time at all that I am sorted for life so
it's not necessarily a money thing for
me I am already in forever money my
money is spinning right around up at the
top and never to come down it will just
stay up there continue to rise I can you
need to flip I am passionate about
fighting fighting is what I love to do I
will continue to do it as long as I am
healthy and willing to put in the work
that it takes to do it takes a lot of
work it takes a lot of trauma on the
body to be able to be fight ready for a
contest so as long as I'm ready as long
as I'm able to do that I will continue
to do that I will not be stupid though I
will not be I will not notice things
about myself and then continue to do it
like many others before me and then then
no no strength their health is
diminished they can't string a sentence
together
it's a dangerous Lucas business and I am
aware of that
thankfully I'm in a position of great
wealth I do not need to do I'm doing it
for the love of it so I make my decision
when the time comes
what if Connick jr. wants to go into
fighting because I was with Serena
Williams she said I don't want my kids
to be tennis players too much pressure
that's me Joshua the same his son
doesn't want him to be a box that wants
him to go to school
mm-hmm what about you no I say Lee will
educate my there not as two things that
I am very very good at making money and
studying and training how to fight
that's it I will I will teach my son how
to acquire wealth and I'll manage
business and I will teach him how to
fight so if he wants to get in to the
fight game I will guide him I'm not
gonna shut keep him away from what has
given me the life I'm him the life that
we currently live I'm gonna guide him
into that so I'm all for it white life
is full life is pressure you know me in
voice shy away white or there's too much
pressure in tennis in a hitting a racket
that's anything you do at the high
pinnacle is pressure so teach a kid what
you know when what you're best at what
I'm best at is training in martial arts
and making money and I will my son would
be an expert in both of those what way
he decides to do it will be up to him
again I will guide him whatever way he
wants to do I will not force him at all
my coach my coaches coach once told him
never ever approach a fighter or an
athlete that's training in your gym and
say and offered him a fight never never
do it because then at the relationship
is weird already the athlete must come
to you and seek a fight and if they seek
a fight then then we can decide when
where what that's how I will play it I
will never approach here fighting on
this date not see I will bring him into
martial arts he will learn how to fight
and defend himself he will learn he was
study business and finance and then
we'll go from there you'll see what's
what but I would be proud if he went in
and fought and represented our name I
would also be proud if he slotted into
all these entities that I am building up
and began to run these behind me and
then when I'm gone he can take them over
so whatever he wants or he wants to just
go low-key and do something way out
left-fin stack the woman said if he
wants to go Pullman one of the
interviews what would you feel like if
you wanted to plump and I'm like I've
got him into it now if you go so I'll be
proud of my son whatever he wants to do